how we've uh how has it been since uh
that episode and how has like life been
in japan over the last year oh man you
know interestingly enough and i i hate
to say it it's been a little sad only
because i really haven't gotten out of
the house much and like i can't i can't
figure out if it's because of the
situation the world is in or because now
i'm officially a workaholic so
i can't figure it out i think i think
i think i know which is the answer to
that one um
if i had to say just a distraction
uh yeah it's probably just like a
combination combination of both you know
definitely i'm also a workaholic so i
know it's the second one oh man i how
did i outed in front of everything
what can you do that's how it is
married i i remember when connor wasn't
a workaholic and then he discovered
streaming and then that was like the
that was like the spare time that he had
is now like dedicated to streaming it
turns out when you don't really enjoy
what you're making it's really easy to
like not do it
but when you enjoy it it's really hard
to not do it yeah right kind of like
spinning bars bro imagine enjoying your
job yeah that's crazy man i just thought
a job was something you don't enjoy but
you do because you have to do it because
everyone does it that's what my
perception of jobs was when i was
growing up yeah well i worked at
mcdonald's for [ __ ] sake you think i
like that i hated that i don't know
where i worked
[Music]
remind me
to remind me kelly do you know where i
worked before i think i do
remind me again
[Laughter]
yeah that's right you must have loved it
cause you never shop about it you might
i never shut up about it because i
[ __ ] hated it
i don't bring a mcdonald's every goddamn
week
another people repost clips of you from
like years ago now talking about how you
used to work yeah before it was a meme
yeah before it wasn't me
except on god's business card it
actually says we used to work at the bbc
did it actually
i wouldn't put it past you to do that
ex bbc employee
no it does it did for the record he's
just talking [ __ ] certified bbc employee
oh god
oh my god
so yeah like do you okay so like on the
vein of that do you probably see this as
a job or is it just something that you
enjoy so much that it doesn't feel like
a job and it's just so easy to do that's
a really good question i mean you know
all before this i was also working for
example service jobs there was never a
point in my life where i wasn't working
a job it was usually a job i didn't like
but i was saving up money to go to japan
you know um and even when i started
doing scythe swinging lessons that was
also something that i had a hard time
with every day waking up and feeling
like going to the same thing it like
wasn't satisfying to me i think there
are plenty of people that can work desk
jobs and office jobs that love it and
have a great time or even if they don't
love it they're fine enough with it to
go home and just have a dream watch your
videos yeah and that's perfectly fine
it's under the impression that people
just went to work and then they did it
just so they could like play games in
the evening that's what i thought jobs
were when i was growing up i
sometimes i wasn't enjoying it there was
some parts i didn't enjoy i was like oh
this is normal it's a normal job but no
i really like it i'm addicted yeah for
me it like comes in waves right it
depends on whether you're working
whether you enjoy what you're working on
or not sometimes if it's if you're
really passionate about it you know it's
just easy to do and uh when you're not
enjoying it then it is a grind right
that's the sacrifice that we make for
being in very lucky positions you know
super lucky yeah but i will say it's
okay to not have a passion i just want
to put that out there
i think it's perfectly fine to just do
do your job that you hopefully don't
hate if you hate i think if you hate it
i think you should stop it um and find a
job that you don't hate at the very
least and then go home and just do your
hobby do what makes you happy i think
that's great um but if you do have a
passion then i think it's it's nice to
at least give it a try to try to get it
and if it doesn't work out it doesn't
work out unfortunately as well most of
the time hobbies or passions aren't
monetizable passions and then but when
you do start to monetize it it stops
becoming your whole yeah
yeah i mean i think it's obviously
you're surrounded in media especially by
people who are passionate about
something because yeah
right you don't get there by not being
passionate so i definitely agree that it
doesn't give you this false sense of
everyone has to have a passion right
right and also it's cool i feel like i
see a lot of interviews that say things
like from people for example like us um
who have been very successful at what we
do i see a lot of people say over and
over again just go for your dream you
can do it if you really believe and work
super hard i know that i've said
something like that in the past but i
want to very quickly correct myself
here's the thing back pedal back pedal
back or back pedal
you need to two things you got to
realize that you're taking a risk you're
making a gamble because you need two
things you need to work hard and you
need to be extremely lucky and um you
need to have both of them you can't you
can't just have one you got to have both
but the problem is if you don't work
extremely hard then there's no chance
there's no chance yeah and it's it's
it's it's scary to take that chance in
your life sometimes because some people
just don't have a safety net and so like
they go
they [ __ ] yolo everything into this
passion and i'm just like i can [ __ ]
do that you know like like i respect
anyone who has who has the guts to do
that like for me like i had to save up
for like a year's worth of wages that i
would could live comfortably on yeah
before i was even comfortable quitting
to try and do youtube it could have been
three more videos yeah i know right
we will never know
the three lost videos that god could
have made in that year
sorry but i i think that even the fact
that you had the balls to do that is
quite admirable because i'm sure there's
a lot of people who want to like you
know get into either what we do or some
kind of creative field that you know
might have a year five years ten years
worth of savings and they could just
never take that first step forward yeah
yeah you know so i think just doing that
like you know for me it's like i was
still at school when i started this
whole thing so you know i had that
safety net of like well if it doesn't
work out i'll just get my degree get a
[ __ ] job it's also difficult because
i feel like when you're talking to other
people who are successful
in that particular field you almost get
this like not not survivor bias but like
everyone's done it yeah so how do you
get an actual view of the whole
uh
the whole picture of the whole playing
field if your only perspective is from
talking to people who've made it you
know sometimes i think like huh but then
how how can you you go you can't go to
someone like hey you've been trying for
15 years and you just failed hey can you
can you talk to you for a moment can you
figure out what's going on like you
can't you know yeah remember that
traumatic time where you try to make it
and you didn't tell me about that you
know like there's you know it's not
always like that where people just do it
forever like people give up for many
reasons yeah just stop they don't
necessarily give up but you know there's
a lot of like a lot of factors come to
play but also i do think that sometimes
i'm like huh maybe i'm just talking to
other people who have just made it too
much and i feel like i can't actually
get a good perspective mm-hmm
yeah i mean i get that and i think that
we've just talked to enough people where
you see certain patterns like everyone
everyone like everyone doesn't everyone
has a different path no not everyone has
exactly the same path but you've noticed
certain patterns that keep cropping up
and you're like i kind of did that as
well and i'm just like you know you it
because because i thought that you know
i thought at the beginning there is
nothing you can do to like guarantee
success and there is nothing you can do
to guarantee success in our fields but
there are certainly things you can do to
increase your chances yeah right and and
and i feel like that just comes with
knowledge right that just comes with
just
the trial and error and just like what
kelly's experience where you start off
you're new you don't know what you're
doing and then eventually you do it
enough and then you're able to get the
opportunity to see what works and what
doesn't and obviously we've all been
very lucky as you say uh as kelly said
you need luck to succeed in this field
oh yeah yeah but there are there are
other things you can do that can
increase your chances of success as well
so there's no guarantees but there is
ways i think that you can increase your
chances what do you think you would be
doing now if you weren't a reaper
man you know
to be honest with you though i
genuinely answering 100 percent honest
i'd still be trying
yeah i'd still be trying to
i would not i just don't think i would
have given up because i don't know what
else to do see that's the other thing
guys if you you got to recognize
it's a gamble so you better like it you
better really really love it so that
even if you don't quote unquote pop off
or succeed you love like every second of
doing it i think is the most important
you know like back when i first came on
the podcast um i feel like i didn't
fully grasp it yet i was so kind of like
whoa i'm suddenly doing really well way
better than i've ever been in my life
this is because i worked hard
i i remember you coming on and you were
so like bright-eyed and just like so
optimistic
i mean that's why i had to like step
back for a minute though and correct
myself and say i was a little conceited
back then wasn't fully aware of what i
was doing but of course once you change
your stance on something on the internet
you're a hypocrite so that's just that's
just kind of how it goes
like start to hit you of like oh this is
what the life is like oh um let me see
that is that's another really good
question you guys got some some bangers
today sorry no it's like interrogating
um let me see it must have been at the a
million
subscriber endurance stream i think that
was when it really hit me things are
going to be extra different from now on
wow that was when we were really popping
off though like everyone was exploding
every single day with with new subs and
new members and and that was like the
prime you know and that was when it
really hit me like oh wow this is the
craziest thing i've ever done in my
existence and i'm extremely lucky yeah
wow and that was kind of when i changed
my stance on oh you just need to work
hard to get far in life
i realize now that's a little conceited
to say that it's not true it's not real
life
do you feel that uh
mentioning that you said that there was
like a big pop off an explosion do you
feel like it the scene has changed a bit
of the the way the viewers interact
changed over the years because i feel
like
the the peak of it is kind of or like
the hype peak it like the newness of it
has kind of died down a little bit yeah
yeah i think yeah it's okay to admit
that it's it's kind of died down a lot
actually yeah um the market is really
saturated right now
yeah you don't say
you don't say first time
um
that is the that is the plain truth of
it all um there are a lot of people
interested in v tubing now it has gotten
really big a lot of people have come in
and also a lot of people have left a lot
of people have tried it out for several
months and realized it's not for them uh
all you know all the power to them good
for them but that's just kind of like
how it's gone you know um
you know that's how it goes with
anything you realize you're into
something you stick with it you realize
it's not your thing you drop out and
that's cool um but that's why there's
been a bit of like a a wave i think and
um
you know everyone i think a lot of
people have you know seen
youtubers they kind of know what they
are especially in like the anime sphere
i guess um
you know and i feel like um that's just
how things go sometimes you know
the longevity of something i hope that
people continue doing this yeah i hope
this keeps being something fun that
everyone can enjoy i i i think vtubers
are going to be around for like the
future because i feel like yeah we've
had our popularity peak especially in
the english uh community and now it is
much more saturated and it i but i don't
think it's like died down i think it's
more like it's just leveled off right
it's
plateaued that was the word i was
looking english language thank you thank
you gentlemen
did you learn that from duolingo
you know people are coming up with new
ideas every day an amazing new
technology some of these you know indie
v tubers with 3d that they're doing is
like mind-blowing
you know and i think it's going to keep
you know evolving in its own way and i'm
really excited to see do you ever feel
like the pressure to have to keep up to
like you know keep
relevant as you know the youtube the the
word every youtuber [ __ ] loves
staying relevant
oh man i mean i think that's a worry for
everyone and if they say it isn't then
they're lying straight to your face at
least is a teeny tiny bit yeah just a
little bit especially when it's your job
you know you you do worry about things
like that but i feel like my interest in
numbers drastically waned after like i
feel like um you know a lot of the core
fan base came in and we still get new
deadbeats all the time always very
welcome and opening to them but um it's
like i stopped caring as much about the
number situation when i started to
genuinely enjoy streaming and making
music um you know
as as me yeah right